the original Times article
um the online not the online version but
the print version of course they can't
change that right that was particularly
ridiculous because it had the heading of
it was academics back bizarre claim that
Jabs May kill right I mean that in
itself with hindsight it's quite an
amusing statement but you want to know
if it's not even funnier it's a double
page spread that this was that this
article was in massive spread on on it
came out on the I'm looking at Tuesday
March the 23rd
and um the head the top headline right
across this right across the top you
know what it says it says Oxford vaccine
that's the AstraZeneca 100 effective
against severe covid in U.S trial
right that's the headline right which we
now how you know how wrong could that be
but here's an interesting thing you may
not your American viewers might not be
aware about this whole thing about that
I mean how much do you know about the
the history of what happened to the
AstraZeneca vaccine in in you know
throughout the world
I look forward to hearing right so the
AstraZeneca vaccine
um of course was produced at oxen and
they claim oh it's not for unlike Pfizer
and moderna it's not the Prophet this is
you know this is gonna this is the UK
you know UK's brilliant research
scientists save in the world you know
um uh without any sort of profit modes
that's the way it was it was sold and
you know that the woman uh is it Sarah
Gilbert who was one of the uh prominent
scientists involved she got a a Dame
Hood very soon afterwards and a sort of
Standing Ovation at Wimbledon Center
Court in in June of that year right so
that's the sort of context of it and
when the vaccines first came out
almost everybody in the UK was getting
AstraZeneca right a because it was you
know it was it was British B because it
was actually even I'd you know the stuff
I'd heard about the sort of you know
what the sort of because of the slightly
different style of accident was you know
even I thought well maybe it's not gonna
it's not potentially as dangerous as the
as the you know as the Pfizer uh
technology right so there was that
aspect of it and and so you know you
know that's what people everyone was
getting that okay
um and you know
so this is this was this was going on
until
um June until about July of that year
then suddenly of course there'd been
stories stories were already coming out
about severe adverse reactions with the
blood clots and there was actual reports
of of deaths right and you know there
was a BBC uh presenter you know you know
the coroner actually recorded it as as
um uh uh AstraZeneca vaccine-induced
death so these stories um were coming
around and there were also stop you were
hearing things like in other European
countries they were no longer they
certainly was stop stopping to give it
giving it to anybody uh under the age of
30 and stuff like that well the
interesting thing was in the UK there
was never enough there's there was never
and has never been any Public
Announcement about what happened to
AstraZeneca right but as early as I
think it started I think that I I went
to my GP
right and asked the question about
AstraZeneca I think it was in uh it was
either might have been August 2021 uh
2020 so this is you know right now
August 2020 what's happened you know
what's happened with Astros said oh no
we're not giving that any we we haven't
got that anymore
what you mean you haven't got it anymore
well we're not we're not being given it
we're not we're not we there's nothing
there are no supplies of it anymore well
is it because supplies have run out or
whatever to Carlos sorry shawl
the reason why they've not made any
formal announcement is because to all
intents and purposes has been completely
withdrawn but they won't they don't want
to they the reason they won't say it
because what made the way around it is
that they claim that you can still ask
for it you can go to your GP surgery or
you can go to one of the clinics and say
that you want to have the AstraZeneca
vaccine and it will be supplied to you
but the fact that most GP surgeries
don't have it anymore and you know very
few doses are being given
you know gets them out on the fact that
they they don't have to admit that this
has been a catastrophic disaster it was
a catastrophic disaster and you know you
know that whole Fanfare about you know
this was this was Britain save in the
world you know doesn't they they stop it
stops the embarrassment about it and and
you know that most you know many
countries in Europe it absolutely is you
know that you the fact they really have
banned it right so Britain officially
hasn't banned it but it's all intents
and purposes that's just to say if
that's just to say thanks it has uh
Shadow banned it yeah exactly
effectively yeah yeah which is
fascinating I mean and the number of
games that are obviously being played uh
I don't know what to make frankly of the
uh the AstraZeneca Fiasco I don't know
what to make of the interaction between
the MRNA vaccines here in the US and the
the Adeno Vector dna-based vaccines
I certainly
um have been struck by the number of
independent failures and errors in the
uh the basic
um model by which the RNA vaccinations
function right the fact that they were
heavily stabilized with pseudo-eurydines
they had no uh targeting mechanism so at
the point that we discovered that they
were circulating in the body that ought
to have set off alarm Bells but in any
case
um I don't know what to make I don't
know how much of the battle
over which vaccine is really a corporate
battle taking place as if it was a
scientific battle well that's an
interesting very interesting point
because when I've raised this thing
about yesterday people The Defenders say
ah now astrovenic is still you know
should be should have been much more
widely available it's just because you
know it's they got muscled out by Pfizer
you know that fires are you know the
advisor modern muscle the mouth so
that's that's the kind of that's the
other argument to sort of you know save
that's that's a Saving Grace argument
which is which the No Doubt government
ministers will probably if you actually
got them to speak about it and never do
but if they if you did they would
probably give you some messaging like
that but can I ask you I can ask you a
question it's quite interesting one of
the other reasons why they were in the
UK they were saying AstraZeneca science
better than fires it was this thing that
Pfizer had to be stored at some
bizarrely low temperature minus 70
degrees and that was a major problem for
you know you were the way that you could
vaccines were kind of like distributed
and and given the UK but apparently
whatever happened to that that
requirement because as far as I know
that's suddenly no longer yeah no longer
they no longer have that requirement
it's always just thought anywhere I
remember but only vaguely some sort of
Revision in that claim very early in the
distribution of these things
um again I don't know what to make of
any of this what I know is that Pfizer
seems to have won out
um and that's the exact inverse of what
should have happened when the competitor
was Johnson and Johnson
a vaccine that I still have concerns
about but
on multiple different levels from the
fact that it's one shot rather than two
that because it's DNA and not RNA the
pseudo-uridine Fiasco has not affected
it
um and the you know this one's hard to
explain but the problem with the MRNA
vaccines
one of them
is that the lipid nanoparticles that are
used to get this into cells
are this is effectively a pseudo-virus
right the lipid nanoparticles are taking
the place of the nucleocapsid but
because they are not the product of
evolution they are completely haphazard
with respect to what cells they uh enter
that's not true for a virus like an
adenovirus and adenovirus has an Ecology
of its own it has a logic and so it
doesn't really have any reason as far as
I know to invade your heart cells
because it can't spread from there and
so the the idea of using
a virus as a vector while it sounds
scary is far safer as far as I would
guess than using a completely uh
arbitrary mechanism like lipid
nanoparticles and so
in any case
the fact that uh Dr Ben and her group
has found an all-cause mortality slight
all-cause mortality benefit with the DNA
based and and all-cause mortality harm
from the rna-based vaccines fips when
Heather and I predicted we said look
none of this the thing that set us off
the thing that caused us to uh join the
skeptic Community here
was that we were told that these
vaccines were safe and effective yeah
there's you know safe means you know
that they don't do harm and there's no
way they could have known that it didn't
do harm two years out five years out
because they hadn't existed long enough
so we knew that that had to be a lie we
didn't know what sort of lie it was
um but
what we said was none of this is safe
because it's all too new we don't know
what the effect is but in terms of the
relative safety the adenovector vaccines
are likely to be a lot safer and if we
had to take one that's what we would do
that's what we said and it turns out
that that is now uh borne out by the
data at least with the J J and I do
wonder about the AstraZeneca I mean the
thing is though that all of the I mean
all of the evidence now is pointing to
um certainly no evidence we even if we
avoid saying how harmful they might be
as you said there's certainly no
evidence that they're safe right and
there's the fires are there's definitely
no evidence that they that they lead to
a decrease in or cause mortality right
but the fact that it's now even that
there's no dispute I mean people might
dispute that there's no dispute about
the fact that it doesn't stop infection
transmission and the fact that all the
evidence points to increased
transmission amongst people that are
vaccinated why is this still going on
why why are there demands to you know
for continual boosters what what's you
know if it's not I mean is it is it now
are we at the stage where the the push
for that is not so much the profit I
mean there is obviously it's still
there's going to be the profit factor in
there but do you think there's also the
side this notion that they want to kind
of like eliminate the control group the
fear of what might happen with the
safety profile I worry very much about
this they're they're fervor to vaccinate
to transfect I should I should be
disciplined about that they're fervor to
transfect people for whom there is
clearly no rational argument young
healthy people did not need these things
no matter what and
the
desire
to inoculate them is bizarre and one
possible explanation is this issue of
the control group I would also point out
I don't know what happened with
AstraZeneca maybe the AstraZeneca shot
is as dangerous as you were led to
believe
on the other hand
if
the AstraZeneca shot
uh has the same relationship to the
Pfizer and modernist shots that Dr Ben
found
with um
with all cause mortality and the
relationship between the J and J and the
the Pfizer and moderna then
obviously there's a compare there's a
statistical comparison to be done
between people who got the one version
and the other and if for example the
stabilization of the mrnas using
pseudo-euridines in every uracil
location
um if that turned out to be a massive
error that caused a tremendous amount of
harm that comparison would show it to
you
um so who knows I wish we we need
institutions that are capable of asking
these questions we need Skeptics who are
empowered and we just don't have it
foreign
[Music]